il n'a que 18 ans un sourire un brin
gêné face à certains joueurs mieux
classés que lui à cyril fruchart membres
de la dame noire a remporté vendredi 30
décembre le 17e tournoi de noël organisé
par son club
une surprise pour l'intéressé est loin
d'être favori au départ c'est vrai que
ce n'était pas tendu au départ
au départ c'était le il y avait mes 30
ans derrière le maître fide il aurait dû
gagner
il était favori et contre le maître vite
par exemple qu'il l'ait fait dit il mais
il a peu raté son ouverture du coup une
partie facile j'ai et c'était surtout
lui qui devait défendre et donc c'était
plus facile pour moi
six victoires et un match nul c'est le
bilan presque parfait de cyril fruchart
pour ce tournoi de noël une performance
qui rend fier à celles et ceux qui l'ont
vu évoluer depuis l'âge de 9 ans au sein
de son club dans le temps il y avait des
grands maîtres joueurs professionnels
qui ont participé à cette heure là ils
n'ont pas gagné mais bon nous sommes
toujours plus content qu'un jeune des
clubs qui avaient été formés et grandit
aulas ne l'avons connue depuis l'âge de
6 ans s'étendent maintenant âgé de 19
ans égale de tournoi nous sommes très
très contents mais c'est personnel
et c'est paulo club est toujours content
que les jeunes car en tout 43 joueurs
ont participé au tournoi organisé par la
dame noire le prochain rendez vous pour
les passionnés de l'échiquier fixée au
mois de mai ils tenteront alors de
mettre échec elle la nouvelle pépite
locale